in Torquay is Southeastern gaziante
province of Destruction is overwhelming
as Stephanie Decker reports thousands of
families have been displaced and homes
reduced to Rubble
nordagi has been frozen in Time Life
changed here at 4 17 a.m that Monday
morning you can just get a sense looking
at these buildings this is an entire
residential area this has been
completely destroyed but you also have
other parts of the city where the
apartment blocks still stand but they
are so structurally unsafe and if you go
through them
there's an eerie feeling here of
where life is absolutely changed where
it's ended you can see the balconies you
can see the incredible cracks of the
buildings this is why also the Army here
is telling us to be very careful when we
operate
because of the danger of them actually
having pieces fall off
um a lot of people we've been talking to
saying that within seconds the entire
Earth shook the entire building shook in
this building we're told only two people
lost their lives the rest managed to get
out and then of course we have the
ongoing rescue and Recovery operation
incredibly in the last 24 hours or so
they managed to pull a mother and her
child from this location
one of the workers here one of the
rescue workers is a volunteer he has six
members of his family still left on the
second floor of this building you have
relatives as we've been seeing across
the southeastern region waiting for news
of their loved ones this lady has been
sitting in prayer
for over an hour
and then
now when we're walking through these
apartment blocks you see
television screen a chandelier
curtains still hang
it's incredibly difficult to convey the
sense
of Devastation the sense of loss
one man we spoke to who has a shop here
and also is from here said life is over
in order nordici is no longer on the map
so uh
very difficult to see how in an instant
Everything Has Changed For over hundreds
of thousands of people
Dr Iqbal Omar is the head of Health with
the humanitarian organization Mercy
Malaysia he joins us from Adana now we
appreciate your time what are the
critical humanitarian needs and are
required right now
uh currently I'm at the ground in
osmania area so the needs are I mean uh
uh like shelters
winter blankets food
and I mean you you I mean they left
their houses with their own clothing so
they they didn't carry much and so they
need almost everything in the feed the
trauma that people are facing there is
just immense isn't it what have your
team been witnessing what have they been
saying
uh we have visited a few uh evacuation
centers in osmania area people uh uh I
could say they're coping quite well we
with us also we have a mental health and
psychosocial Support Officer so we have
some assessment and uh we are trying to
assist the local psychosocial team uh
with some hard ways as well as
activities and parties participate in
activities
what are the challenges thing that are
facing Aid organizations like yourselves
as this crisis continues
uh basically I uh uh I mean we were I
mean we are we were able to provide uh
the the some immediate relief uh items
uh but um uh sometimes the transport
transportation to like we wanted to move
on to other areas the the weather is an
issues because of the snow and icy roads
so otherwise I think we don't have much
of a challenge I think
what is the focus then of your
organization right now
oh currently uh we are doing assessment
and relief so focusing on health needs
as well as
in working with the uh
I thought the local uh Disaster Response
organization we are looking into the the
temporary housing like containers
providing containers we will be
collaborating with them after the
assessment and also to provide the
healthcare services because we are our
team is working with the two Malaysian
uh practicing in uh turkey so we are
providing the mova clinics in evacuation
centers and also to expand our
psychosocial Services we have just
started today then probably will expand
to other places if possible and of
course immediate relief to provide the
immediate relief items like the blankets
uh child essential needs like diapers
some children food and also the food
pack to their families right
believe it there Dr Iqbal Omar thank you
very much indeed for joining us
you're most welcome thank you for having
us